place beauvau c'est donc un rpr qui
succède un rpr le fauteuil de charles
pasqua sera en effet désormais occupé
par jean louis debré l'un des hussards
de jacques chirac actuellement numéro
deux
dans la famille debré jacques chirac a
donc choisi jean louis une pioche facile
le porte parole du rpr est un chiraquien
pur sucre et bernard son frère jumeau
lui s'étaient mis au service de balladur
né le 30 septembre 1944 jean louis debré
pas sur l'adolescence à matignon où son
père est alors premier ministre matignon
qu'il retrouvera en 74 en tant que
membre du cabinet de jacques chirac il a
enlevé sa robe de juge ou je crois et
ferai le rejoint la politique la grande
affaire familiale député de l'eure c'est
surtout à l'intérieur du rpr qui se fait
remarquer fonceur est toujours en
service commandé dire tout ce que
parfois jacques chirac alors isolé or ce
coup bas
il ya d'abord ceux qui le conçoivent la
politique que comme étant la de la
trahison du renoncement des combinaisons
partisanes et des alliances
et des alliances contre nature
adepte de la méthode chirac secrétaire
général adjoint ratissent la france rpr
et rapporte fidèlement ce mais les échos
de la base à chirac en sus de tempérer
lui se dit tout le contraire d'un
diplomate en dehors de la politique jean
louis debré aime écrire des romans
policiers sa nouvelle charge à la tête
des polices decrow pourrait donc lui
fournir de nouveaux sujets d'inspiration
même s'il devrait avoir beaucoup moins
de temps libre pour l'écriture